so quick uh so strong are we going to
see knight takes bishop no we're going
to see
come forward and if the king steps
forward then rook check
on h5 yep so the black rook is going to
protect its own pawns it's going to
swing across with a check and now knight
takes bishop
maybe if the what if the black knight
takes the white bishop the white rook
will slide across one square probably
and uh pinned this knight it's still not
over it's still not clear at all you
didn't want to take that knight back
with your pawn because the black king
could recapture so
okay king moves to the side
oh okay and okay offering a king a poor
name game now for rosie he's hoping the
rooks come off because then the two
black pawns connected
oh okay
he jumped wesley saves the game
miraculously because now is king versus
king he put his king on the wrong square
and walked into a check allowing wesley
to save the game
wow wesley saw shaking his head he was
about to win this game a draw is not
what he wanted with the white pieces